it is quite interesting to explore the  inner workings of great minds and  logical questions arise for as to why  jung decided to embark on such a journey  for starters we need to understand that  this was the beginning of the 20th  century it was a very tumultuous time  and the groundwork for self-exploration  was quite fertile world war one had  started the church was considered of  little importance economic fatalism was  prevailing and the modern man was in  search of a soul it could also be that  junk realized at some point that the  material world isn't all there is  daily life and everyday experience are  so tedious and superficial at times that  living becomes quite unbearable that is  probably the reason he decided to  approach life from a more experimental  way he surrendered to his dreams and  fantasies and the red book is the  manifestation of this surrender